[Applause]
people of the internet's retro recontour
here welcome back to harry potter
quidditch world cup
guys
in part one that was the first time i
had ever played this game had an
absolute blast it's been a little bit
though so we are ready to jump back in
i'm gonna have to see if i remember the
controls here because i've heard you
guys were let me know in the comments
that the difficulty definitely ramps up
especially when you get to the world cup
level i'm hoping that while you're still
at hogwarts uh it's not gonna get too
difficult but honestly last time it was
just so
easy that i i hope it's a little bit
more difficult than that match with the
hufflepuff would you
let's break the question and may the
best team win oh wait so this is for the
quidditch cup okay interesting so that
means i must be really close to
unlocking the world cup i don't know how
much you have to if i have to play the
hogwarts teams multiple times or what
but
it's like okay here we go i'm speaking
to you from a pack stadium here at
hogwarts my good friend and well-known
critics expert seamus finnegan joined me
for today's game between gryffindor and
hufflepuff
looks like we had a nice sunny day here
at hogwarts
you've guessed yourselves
i think she's the only referee
[Music]
although remember in the books like when
snape would referee quidditch
oh man that's just something like i feel
like we miss out
on not seeing that in the movies that
would be so great
there we go okay all right
so i remember the basics of how to pass
and how to score
but what i don't remember is like all
the uh the more advanced stuff
okay so that's how i steal it right
there
johnson
wait who is that who is that being
thrown too
yeah i'm gonna have to remind myself of
all the other okay so
what does x dude
[Music]
oh let's get rid of it let's get rid of
it
okay so wait i've got y right now
okay that's for the bludger
and it worked we actually connected with
that
oh nice okay i think x is for the dodge
maybe
oh wow
[Applause]
whatever it was i just used it so
gryffindor
yeah i mentioned last time how i really
do like though how they
balance out the idea of the snitch
[Applause]
how it has that meter at the top
and how like right now it would benefit
hufflepuff to catch the snitch as well
right
because they would still win the game
even though i've completely dominated oh
goodness
special move
okay we dodged it we dodged it
[Music]
no there was there was another way to do
the special moves
[Applause]
maybe it's y and b together that's what
i'm gonna try next time
[Music]
get her no
oh they're going to shoot
they score no
it's because i'm trying to mess around
with the controls
here we
all right we're still up 80 to 10.
[Applause]
you like that one the little fake out
aim a little bit to the right and then
quickly pull it back to the left right
at the end
[Applause]
okay yeah so x is like the the dodge
which is kind of like a little boost
that it gives you
johnson
[Music]
i don't know how uh to use the special
move though
yeah see now it says i've got it
[Applause]
but now it's gone it's interesting
the b was kind of bright and bold there
for a second and then it then it faded
away but i didn't use it i didn't press
b
i did press uh
a though like because a is what kind of
jumps and steals like that
she crosses oh no no no no
[Applause]
we are destroying them
okay team special move yeah that one was
z i remember that
that's easy that one pops right up
so it's the same one every time
[Applause]
i wish they'd change it like a little
bit
there we go
[Applause]
because the uh like the the solo moves
i remember those change it up
they're different
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe i'm not supposed to hold down b
whenever you hold down b
whoa wait it was like a defensive
special move
oh my goodness
hey who you throwing to
what's that
what was that
[Applause]
falling apart oh 150 to 10. this is a
key moment guys
key moment in the game
[Music]
so try and take that 150 point lead
gryffindor
oh yeah i lost it with the blusher
[Applause]
oh man i was like i'm gonna have to look
next time the game starts i can't
remember how to do like the solo special
move
[Applause]
or maybe it's that little move that that
stole it like maybe that's it
but i thought i remember they could do
like a little special thing
when they score two that's not that
team
the team special
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we're absolutely dominating
now
absolutely dominating let's go
gryffindor
and we're not even close to getting the
snitch
though i guess we're just gonna oh wow
that's a nice block
[Applause]
i guess we're just gonna have to keep
scoring until our
because see that's what's so interesting
about how this meter works is because
now they have no reason to
to catch the snitch right now
they have no reason whatsoever
and honestly like if you're thinking
about it if you're playing real
quidditch like if you're a gryffindor
right now
your goal would just be to like
i feel like you wouldn't even really
want to try to score that much right you
would just want to go like all in on
defense
and like even even helping harry to find
the snitch a little bit like maybe even
start dedicating other players to kind
of help out looking around for the
snitch
[Music]
and then you just like tell the beaters
don't even worry about this the opposing
seeker right now just focus solely on
hitting the bludgers at the chaser i
mean that would be my strategy you know
if i were a uh quidditch coach
she flipped it okay special move right
there
see how it said special move
oh nice
yeah let's see when i get the ball it
goes away so that that special move
is just referring to like that little
defensive special
so i don't know what you have to do to
unlock the the team special
i don't know if it's just kind of random
or what
let's get a bludger going in there
oh we missed though that time
and then steal it right at the end
it's just so easy to steal right now
like you press a it's
it's just about a guarantee every time
come on blood i mean
fred and george you guys i see you just
take it right back
[Applause]
oh i actually tried to switch to the
left at the last second but
didn't go through
yeah i'm really curious to see what
happens though after we win this match
like what is it
do we immediately unlock the world cup
and how much does the difficulty ramp up
you know
[Applause]
dude we are absolutely 240 to 10 are you
serious right now 250 to 10.
who takes it
[Applause]
[Music]
come on shoot it
yeah see like right now i have this
special on defense and it's just this
little thing
i mean it's cool right but it's at this
level it's so easy to steal
with just pressing a i'm assuming as we
go
hopefully it gets a lot harder to do
that
it's like old school nba jam remember
when you just like run up and shove the
guy to steal it
it's like if you get close enough it's
almost a guarantee
no fouls
[Applause]
all right we gotta be getting close to
the snitch now right
oh
do dude i needed sand
[Music]
looks like maybe two more scores will do
it we'll trigger the snitch
oh whoops didn't mean to do that
[Applause]
yeah i've only gotten one of the team
special moves this game
[Applause]
maybe one more score
team special move let's do it
and you can just instantly press it like
when you get a team special
i just pressed it right away i didn't
have to be close or anything
yep you guys know what's about to happen
you guys know what's coming
[Applause]
[Music]
all right now it should be time for
harry to grab the snitch here
did you see that it just like dropped
back down
what the heck
i don't know what that i'm pressing uh
why
it's kind of weird it looks like they're
trying to like
jostle from side to side
[Applause]
i cannot believe it dropped down just
because i did the special moves
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
it up nice it i wish there was a way to
like make the passes
faster without having to hold it down
there we go there we go
dude please let me catch the snitch
here we go here we go here we go
at last indeed
all right we gotta stay in the line here
[Applause]
yep use that boost
oh yeah look at that look at that look
at that
blows in harry close in
honestly i don't even care if hufflepuff
catches it at this point right
here we go dude here we go
yeah
let's go harry
oh i thought were they gonna do the one
where he catches it in his mouth
[Applause]
[Music]
gryffindor wins
let's go
yeah good game good game good game
hufflepuff
all right match result griffin will
rinse 480
to 10. i think we need to ramp up
the difficulty of it we had 35 shots
zero saves 33 goals so yeah we scored we
only missed two of them
one bludger hit four special moves yeah
let's save and continue oh yeah i gotta
i don't need to save every time i
remember that now
okay at the moment gryffindor at the top
of the leaderboard we have 780 overall
points 310 200 and 170. but they said
they were like this is for the quidditch
house cup right is that what they said
before the game
because i feel like that would be too
soon right shouldn't i have to play them
all again
okay now wait now we're back to the
house challenges
but i think i did all of these oh no
this is a new one combos okay so we did
special moves we did beaters and
bludgers
we did the seeker we actually set the
school record we did tackle and shoot
we did passing so now it looks like
we've unlocked
yet another one here at the end that we
can do called combos i think we have all
right let's do it i'm oliver wood hey
oliver how's it going captain and keeper
you want to know about passing and
scoring i'm your mind
you're the keeper though dude
combo buttons oh the trigger buttons are
going to come into play now okay
interesting
so a it says action pass why does it say
action pass not just pass
rooms to control on the left of course
okay learn how to perform combo passes
string together as long a combo as you
can
go for a goal once you reach this
challenge is all about using combination
moves combos
controlling your chasers you need to
direct one or more combo passes into the
scoring area you'll then need to pull
off a volley shot to score a goal i'll
be there
if you fail to perform a volley shot or
i save your attempt there'll be a time
penalty this is a hard challenge but if
you're fast and successful three times
you might just get that school record
for gryffindor
okay wait how many times do i have the
combo form a combo class use the
broomstick control to direct them
once in range use the shift button
together with the combo buttons
i have no idea what they want me to do
why did i get yellow on those i don't
understand
try double tapping a or b to volley
i'm gonna do that one again though to be
honest
i'm gonna replay that combo buttons l so
do l and r do
different things or do they both do the
same thing
because it said you could do either
washing modes combos
controlling your chasers you need to
direct one or
this is a hard challenge but if you're
fast and successful three times you
might just get that school record for
gryffindor okay let's see that time i
double tapped harry here use the action
button oh he blocked me both of the
combo buttons to perform a combo pass
use the broomstick control to direct it
once in range use the shoot button
together with the clock
special shot
[Music]
okay
so it's like you want to hit it right
off the pass
i really don't understand what r and l
are doing though
because in my head i'm thinking okay if
i hold l it's going to throw to the left
but no that's determined by
by the uh the left analog stick
so i don't think it matters which button
you press you could do l or r
this challenge is all about using
combination
but you do have to hold it down
harry here use the action button
together with one or both of the combo
buttons to perform a combo path
with one or both
ones
i just i let him
alright you know what let's just let's
just quit the game
yes i'm sure and then we're going to
come right back in and try it again
i could just go ahead and score the two
goals get the practice button up and the
combo buttons can be used with the b
x and a buttons
using these combinations could give you
a big advantage during quidditch matches
[Applause]
wow okay
everything was super simple and then i
really feel like they just uh
it's not difficult i just don't think
i'm understanding exactly what they're
asking for yet
oh wait can i not do the i want to do
more training i don't want to jump
immediately into another match
trying to get me to play slytherin here
okay yeah let's go let's go back to the
challenges let's see if there are any
more challenges and also i want to see
what what record i set
because like i feel like if i'm a really
low record then it probably means i
didn't fully understand it
but if i'm a really high record then
that means maybe it's yeah okay i'm
really low
so the house record is 109. my time was
119. i think we've met
i know we've met let's try it again
though oliver let's try it again though
buddy because i
i think i'm letting go of of
i don't know which one's gonna be easier
l or r i feel like a little bit easier
probably
because then i still got my right thumb
this challenge is all about using the
right side of the controller
harry here use the action button
together with one or both of the combo
buttons because like right now i'm just
kind of tapping back and forth
to directly
okay so that got it use the shoot button
together with the combo buttons to notch
a special shot
get it
no how did he block that dude
why was that one green though i didn't
do it off of the uh
yeah i got a penalty for that red one in
the middle yeah let's try it again i
want to get all green
i definitely want to get all green
before i move on here
yeah i'm pretty sure r or l it doesn't
change anything which one but actually
you could hold both of them too let's
hold both of these anything different
holding both of them feels kind of harry
here use the action button together so
i'm just tapping it really fast right
now
[Music]
maybe it has time
that one was yellow too
oh
that one was really good i think i just
set the record though right
unless i get a penalty
oh i did i got two penalties but still i
was one minute
house record beaten
okay one more time
let's do this one more time
because i feel like
i feel like there's got to be more
finesse to it than me just come kind of
like spamming a
while holding l or r
speaking of which let me know in the
comments i know there was
a couple of you last time who
had a pretty good memory of this game
and what works well
oh now see that one i threw right off
together with the combo buttons to
launch a special shot
nope
how is that a combo i didn't think it
was
oh he blocked his plus 30 no it's doing
so good
all right that's fine though we still
said we still set a uh the house record
on one of them i don't think we got the
uh i don't think we've got the world
record or whatever though we'll see what
it is because
i did get i was right around a minute
right
how about this can be used with the
i wish it would show me instead of me
having to go all the way back in like
why wouldn't it just keep me at that
menu right there
i eventually want to go back and do all
of these and try to get the the record
on all of them
okay yeah so we got the score 47 is the
next one
yeah so i guess what i'm really curious
about is
is there any benefit to pressing a
faster as they're like going down or
should i just kind of like is it more of
a timing thing i need to watch how the
quaffle is bouncing back and forth to
beat slytherin all right let's jump in
for another game against slytherin so we
didn't win the world the the house cup
okay he just said let's play british cup
too
i don't think you guys are meaning it
literally like
you're just meaning overall this is all
for the footage
this is lee jordan speaking to you all
right another nice day of weather here
okay let's get those combos going guys
oh nice blah
[Applause]
i see i don't understand the point of
the combos if i can just go up there
and do this
oh okay okay okay
ramping up the difficulty a bit oh yeah
[Applause]
there we go
like okay i can see how the combo was
helpful right there
special moment
[Applause]
come on get him
oh come on
no no no no
that was close
i definitely feel like this is a ramp up
in difficulty
oh i missed that one
[Music]
[Applause]
and then i guess my other question would
be should you just always hold the combo
down
like why not right
oh
now that was really slick
because of how i pressed it
[Applause]
because that person that i hit pass it
to was close enough to the hoof
[Applause]
[Music]
and then i immediately press the button
to shoot
[Applause]
oh yeah
okay
i'm starting to kind of get it
[Applause]
with a quick pass spinnette
yeah sometimes it just like leaves the
waffle just kind of hanging up there
though
yeah like see right there
that chaser was in range so i get the
pass to him and then i've already hit a
before it even arrives so they
immediately hit it in
and make it a really fast one
so it's not just kind of floating toward
them and i feel remember how early i was
saying i wish there was like a way to
make a little quick pass
without holding down
oh
dude
[Applause]
that is pretty sick i can see how this
would be really difficult to master
though
[Applause]
yeah they clearly want you to use combos
in this match though
oh wait what what
snitch is already out
what is this
oh my goodness we cannot let slithering
get this dude
he missed it right there i think i was
close enough but
[Music]
oh my goodness an early snitch let's go
get it harry
there we go
all right man let's do it
let's do it
malfoy does not look happy
[Applause]
andy this combo moves are really
interesting great pleasure
yes let's go
to gryffindor so it was actually for the
queen's cup who would be attending this
year
have a wonderful time and don't forget
to take your omniculus
omni oculus
dude that's really cool so that whole
thing right there was almost
basically the tutorial
four quidditch guards one all right man
all right let's go ahead and hit
continue
so yeah we were 3-0
with a total of 990 points
460 for hufflepuff 200 for slytherin and
170 for ravenclaw so yeah i i don't
think there was a difficulty meter
anywhere but i'm assuming
oh dude here we go
england usa japan germany
france australia
the nordic team spain
bulgaria oh dude they're locked though
65 cards for bulgaria i'm assuming
that's victor crum man
they're supposed to be right
wait do they not have the irish
well like i saw ireland
england okay
dude that is so cool man
all right we gotta do at least one we
gotta do at least one of course
gotta go with the usa
the only choice you could make
oh here we go now here's the difficulty
so right now we have the comet 260
unlock the comet trading company's
finest racing brew
starting to show its age yet still an
extremely versatile so it's unlocked
this one is unlocked nimbus 2000 one of
the nimbus racing company's most
successful models highly reliable with
good speed and exceptional handling not
for beginners and then for this one we
need 35 cards so it's all kind of tied
back to the wizard cards
so yeah i don't think we've i don't
think we've used the nimbus yet so
usa versus england nordic vs bulgaria
australia versus japan spain vs france
oh we got the new uh
the new quidditch pitch area this is
awesome dude
i'm really curious to see the difficulty
really curious
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this stadium dude
are you serious right now
wow man that is awesome
that is really really cool
we do have different referees
[Applause]
and here we go
wait which which one am i
okay
usa is kind of like the the black and
red right there
[Applause]
they all have names too that's awesome
no stop him
she steals it
with a boss
no
who are you throwing to
who are you throwing two way over there
[Applause]
oh we were gonna score right there
dude that was off the combo too and he
blocked it
that was off the combo now they're doing
their own combo
oh my goodness dude this is crazy
this is crazy
[Applause]
we do not have any like special moves
yet though if you notice
he cuts off the box why are you throwing
right
who are you there to
[Music]
oh this is intense man
jerry montz
[Applause]
there we go
dude that was a challenge though
no they saw it right back
the passing is really confusing me now
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no
no
that one got me
[Applause]
they need to move the quaffle better who
are you throwing too
[Applause]
i was aiming at the person in the middle
and then it just threw it way left
[Applause]
wow dude
you really have to pay like i'm noticing
like when they're playing
they really kind of like
go slowly and pay attention to the
direction they're throwing it in oh dude
they're about to score they're about to
score they're about to score
like i'll be honest right now i'm just
kind of going crazy when i pass
[Applause]
there we go
he throws it
over here man robert
i tried to hit it off the combo but he
was right there waiting
oh he got over there fast man
really fast
[Applause]
there we go
all right all right
[Applause]
hey you guys supporting the usma thanks
harry
thanks appreciate it
okay now we've got a bludger and we've
got a special move
[Applause]
see i did a great job with the combo but
i've got a
i've got to do a better job of
deciding where
or or
shooting at the correct goal
he's like see he's guarding right right
now
what no
i wanted a pass
[Applause]
so that move whenever you have it if you
time it just right it's kind of like a
free steal
oh they just got it right back
[Applause]
from there
oh so see he almost got over there
he was on the far right side so i'd do
it to far left
[Applause]
see he's right there though
[Music]
dude
you guys said in the comments man you're
like trust me it gets much much harder
duties right there every time this
keeper is insane
this keeper is doing a really good job
see that time i saw i was like he's on
the right side i'm gonna go
i'm immediately gonna hit it to the left
at least my defense is still pretty
solid
there we go
[Applause]
all right building a little bit of a
lead here but as you all know it's it's
quidditch so
the snitch is the great equalizer right
if i if i botch that whenever the time
comes then it's not going to matter
[Applause]
oh blood your blood your bludger
there we go nice job beaters
oh i didn't throw it hard enough
[Applause]
oh he's actually trying to throw to the
far left one but
went to the middle one instead
there we go all right
getting that lead going
[Applause]
[Music]
oh he made it all the way over
i don't think i held it down the full
amount of time though
oh dude that was so beautiful though
that was so beautiful
you just botched it though
[Applause]
there we go
i wish i could say that was the hoop i
was intending for though
i was actually going for like the middle
one
[Applause]
team special move coming up we'll have
to see if it's a different special move
oh no no no bludger bulger bludger nice
job guys
oh wait we don't have our special move
anymore
that dude was slow was it going so slow
oh they've got a special move
[Applause]
wait dude is that the usa
i thought i was gonna
i guess i guess that was
that makes sense that was my hoot so
that's why we saw usa on mice
[Applause]
oh my goodness dude
oh oh they're breaking out all the stops
now
yeah there we go
[Applause]
like he wasn't passing the guys i wanted
to pass too
[Applause]
[Music]
goes in
there we go he didn't know which hoop to
guard
all right 110
let's get another bludger at them
there we go
i thought he was gonna do the fast one
like where he just
no i was trying to shoot to the middle
[Applause]
they need help
no don't don't shoot
i'm trying to pass
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go
all right
all right all right all right
nice job
[Music]
[Applause]
dude i still can't get over this like
little stadium
how many are there it's crazy
how many are there
36 countered that myself
oh darn it
[Applause]
see that one just kind of was hanging up
there
[Applause]
it's like the steel and the layup right
there man
yeah i see i'm doing better without the
combos honestly
the combos give you like a quick way to
if you can time it just right like if
you see somebody over on the left
oh blodger
like if i see somebody
like there's nobody with me there's one
and then immediately throw to them
and then let them hit it in
like if you see them kind of lingering
close
sort of like an alley-oop almost in
basketball right
so i'm thinking of it anyway
all right 150 to 10. this is big right
here this is big
let's hit a bludger right away
see if we can get a little easy steel
right here nope we missed the plunger
all right we'll just take it that way
come on go give me a little speed boost
here
no who are you passing to
who
there's nobody out there
oh oh they're going for the combo
they're going for the combo right here
but a steal right there we're at the end
before they get to their hoop here comes
usa
here they come they're out on the
breakaway
looking for a goal right here and it's
stolen just before but they steal it
right back fires it in yes
that's a 150 point lead now for the usa
as they lead 160 to 10. i have no idea
what country we're playing this game in
but it is an incredibly
incredibly intense match
oh oh oh
i forgot who we're even playing but
obviously they do not want to let the
usa get one more point right now here's
the stitch though here's the snitch
if the usa catches it they win if not
we will see it end in a tie
[Applause]
which is incredibly rare in the game of
quidditch
sorry i'm focused
i don't know this seeker's name but
they're closing in on this niche they're
getting ever so close
here they go they're gonna have a shot
at it right here it looks like they
reach out for it and grabbed it usa wins
the match
[Applause]
let's go dude
oh man
wow i can't believe how deep this game
is
i can't i mean let's be honest they
could have released like a 40 50 game
that was just like uh we'll let them
we'll let them do the hogwarts house cup
that'll be enough but no they went above
and beyond man
all right guys and with that that's
gonna be it for today's video if you all
enjoy this make sure you give it a
thumbs up that's gonna help more people
find this video thank you all so much
for watching and i will talk to you
again soon